it was a dream and PayDay of a lifetime
for 456 people which turned quickly into
a 15-hour nightmare here's how reality
and fiction collided on Netflix's squid
game The Challenge the challenge was
sold as the Ultimate Reality Show cash
grab with more than 4.5 million dollars
at stake but it's what was supposed to
be a two-hour shoot for the 456
contestants involved allegedly wound up
evolving into something much more
Sinister and Squid game-like than anyone
could have ever imagined first announced
in June 2022 Netflix's reality
competition adaptation of its South
Korean Smash Hit squid game was
originally touted as a real-life take on
the popular survival drama without all
the killing and struggling to survive of
course but not everything was as it
seemed or advertised according to
numerous players speaking to Variety in
an explosive new article these
contestants exposed the Dark Truth
behind squid gain the challenge and the
unacceptable playing environments at the
streaming Giant and allegedly provided
including reports of dangerous
conditions and unbearable filming
schedule and multiple trips to the
hospital a UK player identified as
Marlene told variety
the conditions were absolutely inhumane
and had nothing to do with the game
according to her and others who spoke to
variety multiple things about the game
environments were either changed or not
as advertised as soon as a red light
green light game started people were
told they couldn't have coats on it and
that their iconic squid game tracksuit
jackets must be open at all times it was
reportedly around zero degrees Celsius
or 32 degrees Fahrenheit on the day of
filming a contestant identified as John
said this is not a Bear Grylls Survival
show if they had told us it was going to
be that cold no one would have gone
through with it and Marlene added it's
not like we signed up for Survivor or
Naked and Afraid according to Netflix it
was in fact very cold on set that day
but the company said in a statement the
variety that quote the participants were
prepared for that in a story from
January 2022 contestants told the Sun
that The Frigid conditions and people
dropping left and right with one calling
it a war zone and what made everything
worse was how long they were all forced
to play the first game
operations for the first game are
complete
according to contestants who spoke to
variety the entire Red Light Green Light
game took upwards of seven hours to
shoot for some people and another eight
hours of prep time all in the freezing
cold initially the freeze or standstill
times for the game were promised to be
around two minutes long but that number
was quickly changed to 10 minutes and
then 15 minutes the player identified as
Marlene said she had to wait more than
25 minutes during one round sources at
Netflix confirmed the time increase and
claimed it was for independent
adjudicators to quote assess the
gameplay Marlene said the second time
the song played I saw it in my left
peripheral vision that this girl was
swaying then she just buckled and you
could hear her head actually hit the
ground but then someone came on the
microphone and said to hold our
positions because the game is not paused
after that people were dropping like
flies another player identified as Jenny
also from the UK told variety that the
experience was brutal I've never been
that cold for that long longer period in
my life it was ridiculous according to
her water wasn't even allowed during the
hour's long shoes one player recalled to
the sun even if hypothermia kicked in
then people were willing to stay for as
long as possible because a lot of money
was on the line too many were determined
not to move so they stood there for far
too long a total of 11 people were
allegedly treated by Medics several
contestants were said to have fainted or
collapsed on set due to the allegedly
inhumane conditions and intense rules
one Anonymous participant told the sun
there were people arriving thinking they
were going to be millionaires but they
left in tears people were getting
carried out by Medics but we couldn't
say anything if you talk then you're out
we ended up standing there for 30
minutes between takes some were crawling
by the end at least one was carried out
on a stretcher sources close to the
production reportedly denied that Medics
were called 11 times when contacted by
variety but they did confirm to the Sun
that at least three people who took part
in Squid game The Challenge Island
received medical treatment according to
show insiders not allowing breaks during
filming is standard practice Netflix
insists that any claims of serious
injury are untrue along with the
allegations of inhumane conditions all
the contestants want from the streaming
network is some accountability
contestant Jenny told variety takes some
responsibility for the fact that you
were ill prepared for this kind of thing
with this number of people a television
executive who spoke to variety under the
condition of anonymity concluded it
sounds like this got completely out of
control